[Musik]
ich habe mich gerade mal für Sandra
gemutet es wird natürlich geprankt heute
ich habe kein Eisen mehr oder hatten wir
noch Eisen übrig Leute soll ich noch mal
kurz ein Eisen ohne töten oh nee doch
nicht die mir gegen den eisengosem
[Musik]
wie steige ich denn wieder ab vom Pferd
wie du absteigst
[Musik]
Teppich habe ich dir übrigens gerade ins
Dings gelegt in deine Hausnummer
ich glaube ich hatte Geschlechtsverkehr
glaube ich heute Nacht warum total viele
grüne Dinger
glaube ich muss ihn direkt hinter die
Tür Tür legen erstmal dir dein Zeug
geben wie viele brauchst Du hier
Bruchsteine
[Musik]
Sandra schmeißen
los geht die Party und die Party geht ab
und ich sing hey ab in die Höhle vier
mal nein
[Musik]
komm raus jetzt
wenn du aus dem Schiff willst drücke
shift
[Musik]
wo bist du denn
die Hose Luca
luca du spinnst
der Creeper sieht geil aus ne
[Musik]
okay ich Luca ich gebe dir Rückendeckung
ich bin da im echten Leben junge ich
habe ein Creeper Stofftier gekauft warte
mal hier die schwarze Cola ab das dauert
ja ewig
[Musik]
mit was brauchst du gerade die Kohle ab
mit meinem Schwert genau
[Musik]
holen
dann kannst du hier reinspringen okay
schaffst du das
na klar
damit du kein Fallschirm bekommst sehr
gut so Sandy du hast ein neues Schwert
neue Schwert neuer neuen Schwert heißt
das wie heißt das Nein Schwert Sprachen
lernen Babbel
[Musik]
hier
nein nein Stopp Stopp Stopp Stopp Stopp
nicht mit dem steinschwert dieser Moment
muss festgehalten werden die ersten
Sandra eisenspitzhacke sehr gut
und jetzt aufsammeln kann ich nicht mein
Inventar ist voll
[Musik]
ich kann dein ernst oder Augen
lassen Spinne auf jeden Fall oh nein
nein nein nein
lauf lauf Handy lauf lauf lauf lauf
[Musik]
ihn einfach nicht an oh mein Gott Leute
ich sehe halt auch nicht so viel ich
habe eine Sonnenbrille auf für mich ist
das richtig dunkel ich bin lasermodus
unterwegs
wir schon mehr oder weniger bewusst dass
du mich gerade alleine lässt mit
Creepern ja aber ich leuchte gerade
alles aus 20 Sekunden später
[Musik]
ist alles so spannend heute heute ist
echt eine geile Folge
ist das hier für Knister Sounds
[Musik]
in die Höhle in die richtige
deinen Arsch dein Arschloch ist ein
richtiger Hülle
[Musik]
ich bin gerade irgendwie Tobi langarm
was passiert hier Luca wie lange spielst
du eigentlich von Minecraft 14 Jahre
glaube ich du kannst es nicht
so gut ja peinlich
Diamanten Leute hier sind keine
Diamanten schon wieder irgendwo
Diamanten gesehen
gut mein Fehler Diamant packe ich ein
nee leg mal die Diamanten rein gib mir
mal lieber aus Sicherheitsgründen
soll das Handy noch mal einsperren Leute
schau doch mal in die Kiste
sollen wir Magma Block mitnehmen
Laser
macht sofort das Tor nein
[Musik]
oh mein Gott nein nein nein nein hey
oh mein Gott Leute Sandy spawnt ja gar
nicht dann hier wieder die spawnt ja im
Dorf wie viel Leben hast du
erstmal fressen Alter genau
bin weg
hast du das Schild in der rechten Hand
[Musik]
Sandra nein
Sandra nein das ist nicht wahr wie kann
das denn sein
sondern das ist nicht wahr
sondern das kann nicht sein jetzt bist
du nicht hier wieder gespannt
du bist im Dorf ne
[Musik]
Sandra nein ey alle Sachen dicker
einfach Schild Rätsel dann kann dir so
etwas nicht passieren du hattest volles
Leben ey hier liegt alles rum soll ich
zurückrudern
du wirst mich niemals hier finden du
steckst hier eine eichenholztür ein
Umfrage sagt teleportieren 93%, 1200
Leute sagen wir sollen nicht
teleportieren es ist dann halt wirklich
das erste Mal cheaten in diesem Projekt
es tut mir wirklich leid ich habe euch
gesagt ihr dürft entscheiden ihr habt so
entschieden da möchte jetzt aber auch
kein Gemecker hören von wegen es ist
cheaten oder so
hallo
und alles was in der Kiste ist packst du
dir jetzt ins Inventar eine Ewigkeit
später
[Musik]
muss man was drücken sehr gut
boah Leute war das anstrengende Höhle
ich liebe es hat Spaß gemacht bin weg
nein du musst doch einmal dein Teppich
anschauen habe ich doch schon eine
gefällt mir nicht
ja Leute das Handy ist weg die hat
leider das mit dem prank hat das nicht
so ganz geklappt die ist ja kein mal
drauf gelaufen
[Musik]